Chicago faces an epidemic of gun
violence this year alone more than 2,100
people have been shot more than 400
killed the fourth of July weekend was
especially violence around a hundred
people were shot in just over four days
Adriana Diaz gained unique access in
some of Chicago's toughest neighborhoods
that weekend for CBS n on assignments
Adriana good morning good morning
Chicago police have already seized more
than five thousand guns from the streets
of the Chicago this year young men that
we met on the south and west sides told
us how easy it is to get illegal guns
and why many never leave their homes
without one I know people who came wall
from a house to the stove without it
going to them why is that a reality why
do people feel like they have to have a
gun on them because people get me killed
nothing right is that it I got shot
twice now I thought it meant gone but
I'm still here so that's God I know that
that's what this here it's hell on earth
the problem we heard and saw over and
over again was guns CBS News gained
access to several crews on Chicago's
South Side
that's a mac-10 a semi-automatic weapon
originally designed for military use and
illegal in Chicago this Southside crew
was affiliated with the group the
Titanic stones they covered their faces
to conceal their identities they
actually told us they hate guns survived
until my family and myself in a better
predict you man so what I need to be are
you just trying to keep ourselves
protected many guys told us they'd
rather risk the police catching them
with a gun than have their rival find
them without one where do you get a gun
like this where did you get this gun
off the streets people subtle how easy
is it for someone to get a gun that easy
and it's worth it for you to keep this
gun we felons know about us but with so
many innocent people dying by these
bullets that's good is it worth it I
mean no and then it ain't worth it but
you got dumb oh god I want to go pull a
drill or drive by you know I'm saying
someone innocent little sister gets shot
now guess what Delmond dumb guys are
coming back and that's how the
confrontation is just gonna keep going
the guns down put the guns down well
probably what happened maybe in the near
future just no time right now you know I
don't want to put my gun down 9 times
out of 10 of innocent ones getting hurt
you know I'm sad if they do come
shooting right now we probably don't
even get shot and we got guns you might
get shot that's how tough it is you know
but I survive or be killed
there's some incredibly powerful
reporting adrianna one of the things
that's really unique about CBS n on
assignment is the ability to show our
audience the ways that you get access to
some of the stories some of the people
that you spoke to how did you start a
conversation and embed with the Chicago
gangs it wasn't easy at first we met a
lot of these guys they were hesitant
they didn't trust us they were like what
are you guys doing here what are these
cameras who are you
and we were with locals who could kind
of ease their worries and tensions and
and really help us gain credibility with
the people we were trying to talk to but
it took time we were there for seven
days from the afternoon till after
midnight most days and we kept going
back to the st. people to gain that
their trust to develop a relationship
and our main person that we focus on his
name is Paris he goes by stash the first
time we met him he didn't want anything
to do with us he was like who are these
people you know you guys aren't really
here what you guys really don't care
about us and you know he totally didn't
want to speak to us the first time we
went back he opened up a little bit more
we went back we interviewed him two or
three times by the end he was opening up
about his fears and his dreams first
time an interview he offered you a gun
first time for sure like your reaction I
mean it's it's nuts to see okay but this
is an important story it really was and
and we're in a
I'm looking at his finger making sure
it's not too close to the trigger make
sure there wasn't an accident well
incredible reporting Adriana thank you
you can see Adriana's full report on the
next CBS n on assignment watch it Monday
night at 10:00 9:00 central here on CBS
and on our streaming network cbsn